[Music]
all nope news no submitted by sexy Lexi
2 2 3 3 that sounds like a cam girl's
name no that's genius she just plugged
herself well look it up sexy like they
did in the comments damn I my googly a
spider was taught to jump on command in
a bid to create an army of pest fighting
robots it's a robot spider you can train
spiders I guess we got to find a you
know I think it's a robot spider it's a
person I didn't like why would you train
you don't have to train a robot you guys
are looking at it wrong ok so this takes
place in Japan what I said lighten this
please ah this takes place in Japan it's
this man in a Japanese man in a spider
suit
what's the thing he tashi he does she
spied on ya oh she's spying on the video
watch she's gonna be a Japanese man in a
big ass spider suit see I told you whoa
you are the solises okay
here you go these things between
platforms is twice Kim's body's length
oh that's her name Kim why she looks so
cute when she Johnny up to six times her
body laughs Wow crazy not a wolf spider
if spiders can join the Olympics we're
[ __ ]
dams I know we shot all spiders mm-hmm
[Music]
why did the spider look so cute though
sometimes they're pretty cute I've never
thought a spider like they're not cute
when they're like you know crawling up
your arm and above I don't like daddy
longlegs but I always thought tarantulas
were cute because they're furry Sanchez
oh yeah yeah it's cuz it's slow mode
that's why they're fast like Oh God oh
yeah even you look scary yeah that's
true cuz when this when that movement
that's that's why that's why I don't
like little dogs you know when they run
their little legs like this that
supposed to be - chillin brushing your
teeth and then you see a little like
yeah you know I didn't know that when
you know people who are like deathly
scared of spiders they can't even kill
them they just can't be around them is
it touching it huh cuz I'm scared of
spiders - right but if I see it the
whole [ __ ] I do that and then that it's
gone forever I'm try to kill damn
oh no I obliterate the [ __ ] out of I get
it - shoot I pick them up and then it go
that to show outside with the spider I
gotta save their life no I throw the
paper away they do but then it's funny
because I don't go far from my house and
then it just probably came back in no
bro I kill them with the paper I flush
it down the toilet I pee on it
no I put until I pee on and then I flush
it you know that makes it oh yeah you
don't have one of these you have one of
these yeah what I mean what do you have
he's not a handle oh it's a handle but
I'd touch it like this I got in trouble
when I was a kid because I wanted to
kill a spider on the wall and I just
ended up kicking a hole through a wall
like some action yeah like that plaster
well you know cuz there's like kind of
flimsy you know a big guy oh yeah boom
and I just kicked the whole the wall and
I got my ass beat so hard [ __ ] so
aggressive scared yeah whenever cheer
like she hates bugs and spiders than
anything but she doesn't kill them
either like so like I would be like I
babe I'm gonna take a bath whatever like
cool probably no they're like I'm living
room and watching TV and I just hear
yeah
I'm like alright grab something to
[ __ ] kill this bug with I go in there
I kill it and then and then we're good
and then we make sweet love spider love
the song spiders dead bye yeah I just
outlined I chalk outline different audio
yeah you should have proposed to her
with the spider would like just like put
a little ring on the spider in it like
oh yeah when you open it the spider jump
you know how much she loves you do you
scare cheer for fun um just like not
nothing super scary nope no fake bugs
that [ __ ] like that but you know I'll
jump out from behind something she loves
that [ __ ] like it's a really fun trick
yeah this is super fun we should do this
all the time when she's taking a shower
that one and it's like a really nice hot
steamy shower go in the kitchen get a
pot fill it up with the coldest water
that you can bring it back hear her
scream ish you ever fell like from
jumping in these oh yeah one time we had
[ __ ] straight-up war in the house our
house is dress so she was taking that
she took the showerhead ah she's [ __ ]
spraying music don't go and I was
running back into the kitchen I was
spray that's cute but it's it's like if
it's relaxed the most relaxing the most
unsuspecting I used to do something
called who's in the house who I'd have a
key to her [ __ ] apartment right and
then I would wait outside and wait
because I'll worry about the issues if
she said she's going to the shower I
will come over then and she wanted in
the shower hide in a [ __ ] closet
oh gosh and then she would come out and
then she's just like Hello
cuz she was like assume somebody's there
and I'm super quiet I just call yeah it
was terrible though cuz what if she was
like Hello oh god that was my [ __ ]
day at [ __ ] hate oh you know what
happened but if she had a knife I feel
that with this guy when I scare him so
when I found out that it was only funny
than me it's her reaction because she
doesn't curse
so I went oh she does cuss when when
when she's well when it's like that and
then she looked at me and I was the only
one laughing and I was like this is not
funny
well what if what if one day you're
doing that and she's like is this David
or this Bane you know the sad thing is
like yeah I just can't even imagine that
cuz you guys even know Muriel so it's
like oh she's too innocent right or
that's our cover-up yeah or is this big
dick Edwin Booth from the closet in cell
phone and she's like oh it's not big
dick Edwin one thing I used to do to
freak out year like this is just cute
when she watches a lot of like the
paranormal activity shits right we'd be
in bed like let's say like the summe in
bed and don't do that that's looking
she's like dead don't stop or like I'll
lay on the bed I'll go see I gotta do
funny stuff like that mice just not
funny it's just stupid yeah yeah but
back to this spider here so you kept
asking if it was a wolf spider a
therapist Regis or a regal jumping
spider Oh jumping wolf spider so they
were these scientists from the
University of Manchester they were
trying to study how these jumping
spiders jump like the actual mechanics
that go into design the robots like that
yes I can design some robot spiders to
fight pests isn't that plagiarism
[ __ ] copying real [ __ ] come up with
drawing ideas
they could have robot spiders around the
house just to [ __ ] around all the [ __ ]
no no to kill pests kill bugs in my
accent well why do I design it Ennis
Spyder why not like a cute [ __ ]
butterfly because our the natural bug
inside creating a robot yeah so why not
make you something cute or something
because the spider has mechanics in
order to kill the bugs so that's why
they're imitating the spider that's why
scientists created that in case you was
perfectly designed already like it for
trauma three
why don't you just put a laser on a
butterfly I know fabulous Lloyd I
wouldn't be able to pounce not a real
butterfly a robot butterfly
I want anything a little like dart I'm
so are we going to shark tank I'm taking
it to Lawson yeah I'd do it you would
invest yeah it'll be like laser beams
attached they're freaking yeah but it's
got to be like cute bugs later like
little ladybugs they could be like lady
lady bugs with Warhammer cat lady bugs
with Warhammer there's there could be
like cats with [ __ ] Wolverine or that
already exist cats with laser eyes cats
with laser eyes that killed the mice and
[ __ ] no with like will missiles no the
only reason why it's funny it's cuz of
your face that makes every funny what
make you buddy looks like a baby and now
you're talking like a babies it's even
funnier Oh Bernie I know
just a little igloo but only for so long
cuz he's kind of losing it
no he's not his face is still fat dinner
see it she wants what happened why are
you [ __ ] worried about your cheeks no
I thought I had like a monitor or
something like this in this [ __ ] got
real you stop playing here boy my dad's
got a little why don't they let why
don't they just [ __ ] breed these
spiders and unleash them in the house
because you can't control that
then that becomes a pest - that's the
new pest s Oh long as it's not a [ __ ]
black widow I'm bound like I don't kill
spiders I just leave them in the house
you think you'd be down and live I'd
rather have that than a [ __ ] cricket
I rather have spiders and mosquitoes
[Music]
[Music]